وفق وسائل اعلام امريكيه فان شابا عشرينيا
مولعا بالاسلحه الناريه يدعى جاك تكسيرا
هو الذي يقف خلف اكبر تسريب لوثائق
استخباراتيه سريه في الولايات المتحده منذ
عشر سنوات ونجح في الوصول اليها خلال عمله
عضوا في المخابرات الحرس الوطني الجوي في
ولايه ماستشيوسس اذ كان يعمل تقنيا في قسم
تكنولوجيا المعلومات تكسيرا بدا العام
الماضي بنشر المعلومات السريه في مجموعه
دردشه على منصه المراسله الفوريه
بالعاب الفيديو
وبحسب مقابلات اجرتها صحيفه واشنطن بوست
مع عضوين في مجموعه الدردشه فان تكسيرا
الذي اطلق على نفسه اسم اوجي وكان يدير
المجموعه قال عن المعلومات لحظه نشرها
بانها نصوص من وثائق السريه احضرها الى
المنزل من مقر عمله داخل القاعده العسكريه
مضيفا بانه نسخ كثيرا من تلك الوثائق
باليد لانه يحضر على من يدخل القاعده
العسكريه حمل الهواتف او الاجهزه
الالكترونيه على مدى 20 كانت يعطي زملائه
في مجموعه الدردشه قدرا صغيرا من الاسرار
لكن وعندما تبين له ان تحويل مئات الملفات
السريه يدويا كان مرهقا للغايه بدا بنشر
مئات الصور للوثائق نفسها التي تسربت
لاحقا على عده مواقع ومنصات مثل تويتر
وتليجرام
اللافت في المعلومات التي كشف عنها
الاعلام الامريكي انه يؤكد من جديد ان
القاسم المشترك الاهم في عمليات التسريب
الاستخباراتيه الكبرى في الولايات المتحده
هو العامل البشري وليس تطور ادوات
وبرمجيات التجسس والاختراق والقرصنه
الالكترونيه ولعل هذا ما يفسر ايضا قيام
البنتاجون بتقليص قوائم المسؤولين الذين
يتلقون الملخصات الاستخباراتيه اليوميه
بعد تفجر ازمه التسريب في عام 2010 بدا
موقع ويكيليكس الذي اسسه جوليان اسانج نشر
عدد هائل من الوثائق العسكريه السريه
المسربه توضح تفاصيل ممارسات القوات
الامريكيه وقوات التحالف خلال الحرب
الامريكيه على العراق في المده ما بين
عامي
2009 وتبين لاحقا ان الجزء الاكبر من هذه
الوثائق المسربه كان وراءه جندي امريكي
يعمل محللا للمعلومات البالغه السريه في
عام 2013 سرب المتعاقد السابق مع وكاله
الامن القومي الامريكي ادواردسن مئات
الالاف من الوثائق السريه كشفت قيام
الحكومه الامريكيه بالتجسس على مواطنين
امريكيين ومسؤولين اجانب بما في ذلك قاده
دول حليفه للولايات المتحده
تورطت بها وكاله الامن القومي
والاستخبارات الامريكيه